for the past few months I've been asking
strangers to call their crush and ask
them out on a date for my project series
and so I thought it was time for me to
do the same but before we get there
there are a few things I want to tell
you about this person it's sort of a
complicated love story and as is the
case with most complicated stories there
is a seemingly simple beginning so let's
start there
the Damian this person met was a big
blur there was a lot happening and there
was a lot of people around it's kind of
like one of those memories you only have
because of photos but even if I did
remember I really don't think there was
much to it it was just a simple
acknowledgement that this person now
existed a few years passed before I saw
this person again this memory I
definitely remember and I'm sorry to
tell you this but despite all the fairy
tales you might have heard it was not
love at first sight because the love
this great doesn't start off that easy
it was I saw this person and it felt as
though our worlds collided it wasn't the
kind of collision to ask for attention
it was subtle it was silent
it was the meeting of colors the only we
could see
and has scared the crap out of me so I
made it stomp instead of seeing the good
the potential and how I could fall in
love with this person instead of doing
all of that I decided to make our
relationship complicated despite all
this as time went on I grew closer to
this person
we never formally agreed to be best
friends but the fact is that we were I
grew to learn this person's flaws things
that could get under their skin will
made them sad will made them cry but
more importantly over time I realized
how relentlessly beautiful this person
is how strong they are for putting up
with me for all these years how
resilient they are for forgiving me as
many times as they have without letting
it permanently scar them and how kind
they are for still despite everything
seeing the good and me and so not too
long ago I finally decided I didn't want
things to be complicated between us
anymore
but as is the case with most complicated
stories there is no clearly defined and
so let's cut to now 28 years into my
lifelong love story if you haven't
figured it out by now the person I've
been talking about is me I'm sorry if
you feel that I misled you but I hope
you're happy that I misled you here to a
place where I get the message of loving
yourself across I just feel like we
spend so much time emphasizing that it's
okay to talk about our struggles that
we've lost sight of making it okay to
express our accomplishments most
importantly that it's okay to express
love for oneself as a valid form of love
just as important if not more so
there for as long as I can remember my
relationship with myself has been
complicated but in 2018 I decided to let
go of my fears and uncomplicate things I
know that a lot of people get to this
point of self love in their life but I
feel so lucky that I was able to get to
this point with you all after years of
searching this year I found my purpose
and you all told me it was real so thank
you again a thousand times for helping
me and complicate these
[Music]
[Music]